this is rock bottom we cannot scratch
dipper people are struggling they lost a
smile people are dying how do you run a
hospital when fundings been cut by
ninety-four percent sometimes the snacks
are so shocking you're probably better
off ignoring them even when you're the
man who's in charge you see the people
in the sea swimming the only thing they
have to they can do to just forget okay
we have the Sun we have to see have
Acropolis I hope they're not going to
try to take it away because the only we
have left
how long can an economy hold its breath
here in Athens we may be about to learn
the answer six months ago two people put
their faith in this man finance minister
Yanis varoufakis he pledged to get a
fair deal with their lenders everyone
still waiting what we decided to do
before we were elected and then we
implemented it is to say no to this to
say we're going to take time out we're
going to negotiate with our credit
there's a sensible solution but puts an
end to this vicious cycle the price we
have to pay was that we were being
squeezed intentionally bar creditors
occasion these things here look bleak
variably occasionally there's wry humor
occasionally normality on the surface of
it life is more or less continued as
normal here in Athens Russia is still a
bit of a nightmare the Acropolis is
still a complete tourist magnet but
underneath the surface over the course
of the past six months things have
changed the country has started to run
out of money you can see the hallmarks
everywhere they're most obvious some way
off the tourist trail off the eu-funded
motorways sprouting out of Athens in
places like Lamia a sleepy town 200
kilometres north of the capital this
region is littered with roads to nowhere
here work has effectively stopped the
company hasn't been paid for months most
of the workers have been told to go home
so the people actually come and knock on
our doors we we live with the people we
understand what they're going through
and sometimes one of the biggest
challenges that we face is being able to
convey the messages the agony the pain
of our local societies to the central
government and it's always very
disappointing when the local when the
central government does not respond and
which government minister is responsible
for those decisions this man George
Senecas who looks after the domestic
economy and infrastructure in his office
in Athens watched over by a small bust
of Karl Marx funnily enough a gift and
Germans he admits the talks have taken
longer than expected obviously many
people thought that within this
framework of the process of negotiation
would be faster and more efficient but
think somehow sometimes did not work the
way we're planning so the time is
running short it's not just the
government which is running out of money
Greek people have taken so much cash out
of their accounts that there's less
money in bank deposits then out in the
street all peoples mattresses but as I
said this has gone well beyond
statistics Theo Janoris of elpis
Hospital used to spend time watching the
number of suicides in Greece notching up
week by week two weeks ago his son
became one of them I lost my son for the
15 days ago you commit suicide
there they took his dreams away hope is
coming serezha won the election by
promising the young a brighter future
Bart six months on they're still asking
when Eddie Conway Sky News in Athens